Good morning John Green.  Hey there, and happy birthday.  Sorry I didn't do anything.
In the early days of vlogbrothers we did
a lot of birthday stuff and it got... like
kept trying to one-up each other until
it was a lot of work.  You may remember
this guy, he was one of your birthday
presents.  We made a whole bunch of these;
this one's broken
you might be able to tell.  And you were the
only one with a bobblehead for a long
time, until... I also now have one, and you can get a set of both.
I gotta know who's still got any of these.
Definitely a different level of quality
in the new ones.  I think these look
better but you know, there's nothing
wrong with this.  If you were wondering what
it looks like without the head as you'd
spring. So in order to alleviate the
blinding pressure of having to have an
even better birthday present than the
previous year we just stopped having
birthday presents at all.
What do you need?  You got a beautiful family and a home and a Chevy Volt...what
else could a man ask for?  We're headed up to our 10th anniversary on Youtube. 10 years
of doing this.  That is very exciting.
It's also perplexing, like I don't
remember a lot of the stuff that we've
done.  We've done many stuffs...so many stuffs!  This week Grace Helbig uploaded a
video in which she put stuff on her head and then tagged me..."and I'm tagging the vlogbrothers, either one."
as if I haven't already put stuff on my head.  Grace, have
you not seen all 1,427 of our videos?
Grace, you are nine years behind us.  Not that
I mind, I have a bunch of stuff and I'm kind of an expert at this.
I have so many more things that I did back in 2007.  I can do this all day!
This is actually the concept Chevy Volt.
I was so excited about this car when I
was writing for EcoGeek that i bought a
die cast version.  Na-haw!   Other things I've
been excited about my life and no longer am really...Assassin's Creed.  That was
fun, back in the day.  It's okay to change your mind about what you're in to,
but friends, I am still into this.  Pwuh! Pyah! Peh! Egh!  I got yeti in my mouth.  Ten years later it
remains very exciting and weird and
always i'm learning stuff about the
world than about myself.  It's made me like people
more.  It's made me like myself more. I mean
we've been able to do a bunch of cool stuff.
Being able to launch things off of this
and j'st try new things, and have ideas so
great that this community has been so
supportive of new things new ideas. and
as long as they hit that mix of being
like good for the world, fun,
interesting, good for the community
then I don't feel like I'm betraying any of
what we've built here and that's the
important thing, ultimately.  What do you
think, Yoshi?
And I will say that a lot of the ideas for new things to do have been Hank ideas, have been my ideas,
whereas the best ones have been your
ideas, John.  I'm thinking of two major ones.  Ah,
this in the first place.  This was all your idea
and I just followed your lead.
I didn't know what we were doing but I
was convinced that you were right,
that online video was an amazing glorious thing, even though I wasn't into with the way that you were.
And of course our
upcoming Sports Network, which ah, remains
unnamed at the moment...Grace?   I hope that this
counted as me putting things on my head.
(ab-bis-sij-sta) This Snatoms molecule from Derek
from Veritasium's new Snatoms kits. They're
magnetic!   They stick together, huh so cool.
You can build molecules.  I may be a
bit of a dork.  And John, happy birthday.  Get
ready to celebrate our 10th anniversary,
which we're gonna do in the real world
in Boston at NerdCon Nerdfighteria
and if you can't do that and you're nearby
Minneapolis, maybe you can go to NerdCon
Stories instead where John will be but I
will not, because...
And maybe I haven't said this on this channel yet, I've said it a bunch of different places,
I've alluded to it but i'm having a child,
with Catherine in October, so I'm on travel
moratorium, which is lovely though i do
like, I help out with the content for
NerdCon Stories and it does make me
jealous every time I'm in one of those meetings
I'm like, "This sounds like a really good
conference..."  But hey, do I do this for me
or do I do it for other people as well?
Other people as well, and also for me.
Allright! This one didn't really have a point, did
it?  Ten years, it's comin'.  I just did the
math.  People have spent over 50 lifetimes
watching vlogbrothers videos.  We're just
killin' folks.  Eatin up human lifetimes to left 'n' right.  Hopefully, it's worth it.
John, I'll see you on Tuesday.